bella tutti ragazzi e prendere io che
sono video sono fatti j
e ci siamo tornati su happy with e belle
queste partenze così a caso ragazzi non
fate domande perché ogni tanto mi
sveglio così che deficente del solito
perfetto ragazzo allora siamo
che cosa fa non siamo partiti c'è nonna
che cazzo successo lega morto non sa che
cosa fa e mai passo cioè di come stai
default madonna ci disastro
ciao padre di luca ascolta un attimo non
è che perfetto ai primi venti ragazzi
abbiamo scoperto che muovere le spade ok
anche se non ho capito allora che bubble
senza cipolla stanza picanto mi hanno
convinto che muovere le spalle come un
mongoloid equivale a essere una macchina
mortale
voi andate in giro così fate disastri a
caso ce ne rendono ha senso prova è
pieno di significato sto livello cercai
credetemi non ho mai giocata una roba
così bella rochus
ma perché ma perché ha fatto sera vado
fuori esco con le spalle così voglio
vedere i disastri tuned target cosa mi
piace il nome 6 meglio cosa sei devo
salvare luke aspetto sventa svelta seta
ops mi è caduto guarda che ops mi è
ricaduta non hanno giuro beh non è che
non volevo salvarti che mi è caduta la
spada quindi non voglio salvare gli
occorre al massimo lo ammazzo cioè se
proprio ecco esattamente quello che
volevo gente va bene va bene solo perché
sono un bravo ragazzo ti salvo un occhio
regalato un pene nuovo non so se ti
piace sentite lega non riesco ha saputo
anche buono chiare sistema accetta senza
breaks l'ho preso in faccia di te che
cazzo fai ragazzi ballano tutti non si
sa per chiamano il burn prof
questo perché non c'è non c'è favi già
in quella classifica li vede mani di
batterla subito
i ragazzi stessi livelli io non l'ho
capito
la prima volta nella storia che luke non
è un cazzo di essere inutile la prima ma
il successo non ci credeva facciamo
senza perché cazzo di salto ha fatto che
non so se riesco ma ci provo
ok lo lanciato di brutto ma non ha fatto
un metro poveri il rainbow fall mi piace
questo sempre col ma perché si vive di
sempre con luca io diro cosa ho fatto
tu sei stato è un livello dove giro a
caso bellissimo da farmi natio che non
sei più figo livello il parcheggio posto
dubbio senior se è questo che in questo
mi piace mi piace livelli così tipo che
cosa fai look sopra ok forse non lo
sapremo mai ekoto prezzo compreso gli
occhiali adesso ti adesso ti mangio il
culo
questo è violento però faccio vedere se
le squadri farlo tipo proprio un cazzo o
peggio ho fatto l'ho fatto ragazze vinto
la bottiglia fantastica ormai ragazzino
non mi stupisco pd cioè evito di
stupirmi perché gli schiavi di bozze
così se non ed erano non sono morte no
no no ma è come os è per niente per
vincere devo andare con sotto annuncia
arrivo perché ciò la pancia piena ma
perché il peggio di testa
ma chi è prossimo il poco certo ma c'è
qualcosa di impossibile che io non
riesca a fare ancora ok
mio dio
non ho capito neanche ho fatto una mossa
che non però sei un fili con steve
questo devo dire ti metti un po è la
madonna zia ma che cazzo chi concreti di
e bastardo fermi un attimo che questo
steve ti sei dato al circo ultimamente
l'epicità
[Musica]
si no ma [ __ ] ragazzi è difficile
rega ok ho vinto ho detto vabbè ce l'ho
fatta
basta così perché non credevo di uscirne
più non mi faccio domande ragazzi
andiamo avanti perché è stato tra rock
swing è un rock swing perfetto sono
migliorato nei rock swing
allora sì si fa ok perfetto la partenza
c'è il mio braccio un pò meno che
attacco sta continuando con meglio
braccio non si sa perché si è
affezionato proprio si veda dove sto
andando
no dove dovevo aggrapparmi giustamente
sono stupido ho preso stavolta no
stavolta l'ho preso perchè ci siamo oggi
sia mi sembra normale cioè mi sono mi
sono successo non morto un al traguardo
ci sono arrivato senza testa ma ci sono
arrivato perfetto field mall
ok questo non lo facevo da un secolo del
demonio e forse c'era un motivo penso
che fosse un disastro e gas o anche vino
non ho vinto perché sono rimasto
leggermente uno spiedino però più o meno
è stato bello internet my blood 23 di
cos'è mai blog 23 di cos'è sta roba
cos'è sto schifo per mi devo andare
fatemi andare con indiana jones perché
non devo scendere di sotto radio
arrivati alla perfetto apro ci devo
arrivare vivo e possibilmente senza
annusare il mio piede mai di qualche a
[ __ ] impossibile no no no sì eccolo ho
vinto perfetto pollice in su per indiana
ballerino voi ridete schiacciate ma
questo già un futuro nella danza
classica sicuro che i ragazzi che io
vinco qualsiasi duri vado vico quindi
basta provare basta ai viola non ho
capito un cazzo del titolo però mi piace
è una roba dove devo cadere in in dei
jet sono viper festa madonna che testata
no no no
toglietegli togliete grazie ben piacer
merda non so di recente è un insieme di
roba a caso tutti insieme possono tipo
schivare le bombe perché è la mettono
nel culo ok già fatta c'è un fattore che
devo andare prima interni
ok st è stato visto e stato bello anche
questo sport for four cross perfetto
questo aspettavo ragazzi perché
ultimamente list ultimamente mi stanno
sul culo
[Musica]
ho vinto supporto o beccato na va bene
plenty mostra c'è il lancio
dell'ornitorinco dell'orleans scherzando
cioè quasi lanciano per il ornitorinco
perfetta è più vista raggiungendo dei
livelli secondo me conquisterà il mondo
prima o poi perché è assurdo vabbè
ragazzi la slanciano perry l'ornitorinco
contro la gente non ero dinamico però
per in ornitorinco qui non è normale
sì l'ho preso nickname nei maroni
perfetto come ultimo ci avete un culo di
merda rai così se ho vinto a che hanno
riconosciuto babbo natale a beverly mi
ha concesso la vittoria è stato buono ma
nessuno lo sa l'inglese non so scrivere
atac decentemente entering the hall
cordon va bene ascolta zio o una zucca o
una zucca che non ha voglia e tutti
chiamano la ciocca stranzi temette è
stato ben no non lo rifaccio questa
abbiate pazienza nome jump v1 questo
questo mi piace devo saltare record liuc
è già morto che a caso devo saltare
mi piace male direi di sì ci prova cipe
si scassa fa la bici in un momento di
merda
adesso eccolo si sia le eco stavolta ci
siamo ragazzi ci siamo tipo superman non
c'è chi affacciata e non ho vinto perché
mi si è staccata la testa ma porca
[ __ ] slang dark line dunk cioè mi
piace cos'è
no ragazzi ragazzi l'epicità l'epicità
di questo livello dove o non ho fatto
che nessun tecnici che ho vinto io il
mio abbraccio andrà bene uguale perché
ecco mi sono portato via il canestro
direttamente o chiedo ai ragazzi ne
facciamo mio come al solito prima di
concludere non fa vj nutella revenge
revenge l'hai scritto giusto oggi i
ragazzi con l'inglese ci stiamo vai fa
rivendicava nutella va beh quella è la
nutella mi sono più un contenitore di
detersivo scadente va beh non ci prova
uguale regala anche sermi mi sta
piacendo finora solo che non ho capito
cosa devo fare di qui o demolito luke
come se non ci fosse un domani però
perché fa vj e la sbornia
voglio sapere chi fa questi livelli
perché non c'è fa vincenzo a questo
livello please va bellici gioco però
abbiate fiducia a b paziente valigia e
la birra sbrigate dove la birra e lì la
birra ma col qual è il senso di questa
cosa perché ma questa cosa
cosa ho giocato giocatore david j rock
swing ragazzi faccio un ultimo perché
non è non so aggrapparmi più alle cose
io non so aggrapparmi più alle cose ma
porca [ __ ] non c'è più non riesco ad
aggrapparmi neanche ok
mio dio gli anni per fare sta stronzata
ho saltato tutto a livello pro ho vinto
non si sa con la mia testa non ha vinto
proprio dai è rimasta fuori quando
ragazzi posso concludere qui perché mi
sto oggi per oggi basta direi concluso i
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto un assetto ragazzi se il video
è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come noi
via tra tale sezione però se volessi
discrete lì ci vediamo le passioni dei
ragazzi